okay we got a 2022 Dodge Challenger
we're going to do a universal
key take a
battery insert the
battery so we're going to take a
flathead
okay got the red light flashing
now that that's on we're going to take
our okay we're going to take our
Universal
key go to
Universal go to
make going to go
to
dodge going to go to
Challenger select the year
2022 433
mahz generate Universal key so you'll
stick that in
there okay so now we're going to go back
we're going to exit out
and I like to check the frequency make
sure it's programmed
in 43392 so we're good
there okay so let's go plug into the
star
Port okay we're going to pull this panel
down we're on the passenger side
let look and
see there it is I don't know if you can
see
it but there's your starport connector
right now so we're going to connect into
any one of those open slots there open
slots
there right
there okay now that we got our star Port
connected going to plug in
it never reaches over there so probably
just take an
extender okay let's FP this into the OBD
this is right
here okay
okay so now we got this plugged
in plug that into there that way we get
some
power there we
go man that extension cable is so nice
Mak so much
easier
okay so now we going to
connect going to go to emo
same
thing I just heard a connect over there
now we're green and blue we're
good we're going to go to
dodge we're going to go to manual
selection and your hazards
on North
America
Challenger 2021 2023 smart key
yes
okay okay control unit read the password
first turn the connection off turn the
hazards on hazards are already on oh got
to connect to my
Wi-Fi password it turn the ignition off
and turn the hazard on Hazard are on
Wi-Fi is connected
communicating reading the password the
only way to read these passwords and be
able to do anything 2018 and up is if
you have this starport
connector which it is the ADC
2011a I'll put a link down below for
that password is
5283 take a
picture it saves it 95% of the time I
just like to take a picture just in case
okay we're going to go to keyless
system key learning key
learning
yes
okay it saved the password already
so we take the
key going to hold it near the start
start button unlock button
twice in 60
seconds okay so I was able to put it
here and the center console and it
grabbed going Lear the next key
no exit
Okay think we're good so we're going
[Applause]
to there we
go we're well
done km 100 Universal key 2022 Dodge
Challenger